i'm really really excited because i've
been trying to do this forever and
even way before covet but i didn't have
a place you know i've seen all the
venues i've seen all the
the residencies from all the other rock
bands i wouldn't seen them
the strat just gave me a they
welcome open arms whatever you want to
do so i'm really happy
and that room is awesome perfect size
well i've got three bands i've got
chicken foot my favorite band my new
band the circle who's really my band now
and my old band the wabos who was my
greatest party band in the world we
threw that big party we had people on
stage and had
waitresses bringing us margaritas you
know and and so i'm going to kind of
bring
all everybody in and all my friends that
come to cabo you know toby keith and
kenny chesney country guys and they come
up and and we just play and so the idea
of sammy and friends is whoever shows up
then we just do that and we're going to
change the set list every night
this is an event this is a residency
you're coming to my house i'm going to
create an environment we're going to
have my booze
we're going to have my kind of food so
it's a deeper experience
the excitement about it reopening that's
um
we came in first as soon as we heard it
was going to be reopening
made the deal to do it and when we can
do it you know the room's booked up
for a lot of other stuff so i'm taking
in my little holes now but next year
my dream would be to do a month on and a
month off